des lunettes simule un état d'ébriété un
guidon vous plonge dans l'univers d'un
motard il ne s'agit pas de jeux vidéo
mais d'un forum de prévention pour la
sécurité routière
c'était un test de freinage et on devait
évaluer la liste la vitesse à laquelle
on avait on avait eu l'impact bas c'est
pas mal parce qu'on se rend vraiment
compte de
de l'impact et moi je pensais que
c'était beaucoup plus que ça mais en se
contenant c'est que sept kilomètres
heure sans pression une perception de la
vitesse et des risques pas toujours
conformes à la réalité
un forum accessible 3000 salariés de
l'entreprise
l'objectif les sensibiliser aux dangers
de la route
c'est très très important c'est vraiment
dans notre analyse du risque
un élément primordial aujourd'hui notre
personnel on est quand même dans les
yvelines en parle très proche orientaux
énormément de gens se déplacent en
véhicule il faut vraiment que les
entreprises en plein conte et
l'associent dans l'eure
leur démarche pédagogique auprès de leur
personnel une prévention particulière
cette année envers les deux roues et les
dangers causés par les stupéfiants un
thème choisi pour les ateliers mis en
place avec la police nationale
partenaire de l'opération depuis cinq
ans chaque année on vient et chaque
année on a des questions différentes et
on a un engouement pour ce forum que
nicolas met en place et donc c'est vrai
que c'est toujours plaisant de pouvoir
expliquer les nouvelles réglementations
parce qu'on a un public est très
attentif à ça ça aussi c'est important
un atelier annuel productif en 2015
l'entreprise thales n'a compté que deux
accidents de trajet